foreign
welcome to the swearing-in of the new
Gore District Council for the term 2022
to 2025 my name is Stephen Perry I'm the
chief executor of the Gould District
Council and it is my duty under
legislation to announce the confirmed
results of the recent local Authority
election and swear in the successful
candidate for the minority of the gore
District Council once that occurs then
the new mayor will in turn take the
Oaths of the newly elected councilors to
create what is then the new Council for
the next three year period
the results of the election that took
place on Saturday the 8th of October
have been confirmed following some
inquiry as being Mr Ben Bell receiving 2
371 votes Mr Tracy Hicks receiving 2
363 votes there was one informal vote
and 114 blank votes and therefore Mr Ben
Bell was declared elected as mere either
form
[Applause]
I therefore would like to invite uh Mr
Ben Bell to come up to the Rostrum to
make a decoration for his oath of office
in my presence and once that will occur
we have in our room today former me and
Mr Tracy Hicks who has agreed to pass on
the and actually hand over the Merrell
chain
to miss to to his worship Emir Mr Ben
Bell and then I will then assist the
mayor to um
Adorn himself with the Merrell gowns
that are just behind me here so without
further Ado please come forward Mr Ben
Bell as you wish at the mirror
if you just read that
I Benjamin Ryan Bell declare that I will
faithfully and impartially and according
to the best of my skill and judgment
execute and perform in the best
interests of the gore District the
powers authorities and duties vested in
me were imposed upon me as mere of the
gore District Council by virtue of the
Local Government Act 2002 the local
government official information and
meetings acts Act of 1987 and any other
act dated at Gore this ninth day of
November 2022.
foreign
Mr Tracy Hicks to come up and pass the
chain Mill chain over to the new mirror
okay true
put the man first
congratulations thank you very much
now there is one thing that has to be
done one time in your term is mere you
have to wear the hat
so I think should we make it this moment
today's today
we're good
fantastic
thank you guys
[Applause]
brilliant I thought I'd just make a
quick speech if that's all right with
everyone
um Kia Ora my name is Ben I'm now
officially the country's youngest mayor
ever which is weird to say uh thank you
everyone in the community supporters
around the place uh former former mayor
Tracy Hicks for his 18 years of service
as the mayor of the gore District I hope
to do both himself and all of the former
me as proud
yeah it's taken a long time to get here
we've got a lot of catching up to do as
a council so with further Ado let's
let's get everyone else signed in and
get on with the job thank you everyone
[Applause]
so just work your way through okay
brilliant
uh first up could I please call upon
glennis Dixon
okay I glennis K Dixon declare that I
will faithfully and impartially and
according to the best of my skill and
judgment execute and perform in the best
interests of the gore District the
powers authorities and duties vested in
or imposed upon me as a counselor of the
gore District Council by virtue of the
Local Government Act 2002 the local
official information and meetings act
1987 and any other act dated at Gore
this ninth day of November 2022.
foreign
[Applause]
declared that old faithfully and
impartially and according to the best of
my school and judgment execute and
perform in the best interests of the
gore District the pairs
the authorities and duties invested in
or imposed upon me as counselor of Gore
District Council by virtue of the Local
Government Act 2002 the local government
official information and meeting act
1987 or any other Act
dated at Gore at this 9th of November
2002.
22.
thank you
congratulations
[Applause]
next up could I invite Brett heisted to
the stage please
thank you
I Brett Richard heister declare that old
faithfully and impartially and according
to the best of my skill and judgment is
cute and perform in the best interests
of the gore District the powers
authorities and duties vested in or
imposed upon me as counselor of the gore
District Council by virtue of the Local
Government Act 2002 the local government
official information and meetings act
1987 or any other act dated at Gore this
ninth day of November 2022.
congratulations
couldn't invite Keith favel up to the
stage next
I Keith James hovel declare that I will
faithfully and impartially and according
to the best of my skill and judgment
execute and perform in the best
interests of the gore District the
powers authorities and duties vested in
or imposed upon me as counselor of the
gore District Council by virtue of the
Local Government Act 2002 the local
government official information and
meetings act 1987 or any other act days
of the gore this ninth day of November
2022.
foreign
[Applause]
next up could I please invite up Stuart
mcdonell
I Stuart James McDonald declare that I
will faithfully and partially and
according to the best of my school and
judgment execute and perform in the best
interest of the gore District the powers
authorities and duties vested in or
opposed upon me as a counselor of the
gore District Council by virtue of the
Local Government Act 2002 the local
government official information and
meeting act 1987 and any other act dated
this data at Gore this ninth day or
November 2022.
foreign
[Applause]
next up can I invites Robert McKenzie to
the stand
caveman to the stand
I Robert John Murray McKenzie the clear
that I will faithfully and impartially
and according to the best of my skill
and judgment execute and perform
in the best interests of the gore
District
The Perils or authorities and duties
vested
in or imposed upon me as counselor of
the gore District Council by virtue of
the Local Government Act 2002.
the local government official
information and meetings act 1987
or any other act dated
at Gore this day the 9th of November
2022.
congratulations
[Applause]
next up can I invite Paul mcphail to the
stand
I Paul Neil mcphail declare that I will
faithfully and impartially and according
to the best of my skill and judgment
execute and perform
the and best interest of the gold
districts the payers authorities and
duties vested in or imposed upon me as a
counselor of the gore District Council
by virtue of the Local Government Act
2002 the local government official
information and meetings acts 1987 or
any other act dated
at Gore this day the 9th of November
2022.
congratulations
[Applause]
can I invite Richard mcphail to the
stand please
I Richard Oliver mcfail declare that I
will faithfully and impartially and
according to the best of my skill and
judgment execute and perform in their
best interests of the gore District the
powers authorities and duties vested in
were opposed on me as a counselor of the
gore District Council by virtue of the
Local Government Act
2002. the local government official
information and meetings act 1987 and
any other act dated a Gore this ninth
day of November 2022.
foreign
[Applause]
next up can I invite Neville Phillips to
the stage please
I Neville Gordon Phillips declare that I
will faithfully and impartionally and
according to the best of my school and
judgment
it's acute and perform in the best
interest of the gore District the powers
authorities and duties vested up or
imposed upon me as a counselor of the
gore District by virtue of the Local
Government Act 2002 the local government
official meetings act 1987 and any other
act dated at Gore
the 9th of November 2022.
thank you very much
[Applause]
next I'd like to invite Brahman Reed to
the stand
I bronen Reed clear that I will
faithfully and impartially and according
to the best of my skill and judgment
execute and perform in the best
interests of the gold district the
powers authorities and duties vested in
were imposed upon me as a counselor of
the gore District Council by virtue of
the Local Government Act 2002 the local
government official information and
meetings acts 1987 or any other act
dated at Gore this ninth day of November
2022
foreign
[Applause]
and last but not least could I invite
Joseph Stringer to the stage please
I Joseph Daniel Stringer declared that I
will faithfully and impartially and
accordingly to the best of myself and
judgment SQ and perform in the best
interest of the gore District the Paris
the authority
on us opposed upon me as councilor of
the gore District Council by virtue of
the Local Government Act 2002 the local
government official information and
meetings act 1987 or any other act dated
at Gore this ninth day of November 2022.
foreign
[Applause]
that completes the formalities of the
swearing of the new Council and for
those of you who have been to these
types of meetings before traditionally
we had some other items that were also
dispensed with under statute because
it's the first meeting of the local
Authority
foreign
decided that those more administrative
type matters will be take will be taken
care of at the first meeting of the
council and it's uh as part of its
ordinary business on the 22nd of
November so really we're now at the
conclusion of the formal part of the
ceremony now I am under strict orders to
ask the councilors to not so much remain
seated but remain as an A distinct group
The Press do want to take some
photographs of you out in the front of
the building so if the family and
friends can just refrain from
capturing their loved ones and having
photographs with them for at least say
five minutes that will give the Press
their first dibs at official photos they
might need a bit more than that I'm not
too sure I also understand that some of
the media will want to be interviewing
our elected members so that will take
place at the same time out in front the
building other than that thank you for
coming good afternoon